I'm pissed man and if summer meant the
beginning of heists but it looks like we
got psyched out instead rocks are delays
heists again and this time without a
release date
WTF right I'm livid I'm sick of living
the high life
I'm tired of drinking fine wine and not
being able to use my double sinks I
don't even care if I can now rearrange
the whips in my eighth spot garage I'm
done with this fancy penthouse I'm gonna
be in D in GTA's new update but I ain't
no hipster first things first
Trading Places moving back to my West
Santos Shack it's only a two car garage
though so I'm gonna hold on to my saber
and sell everything else looks like
there's a quarter mil loss in the
process whatever my knees my poorly
lived one-bedroom apartment and garaged
to hold by it said some cars will
transfer over not none some whatever you
know I'm not some materialistic yuppie
all I need are my tunes and my trees and
my hair is gone whatever I hate that
midtown do anyways finally I get four
new hairstyles and 10 new beards whoa
Bros wait your turn you eager beeps
Laquisha has only got two hands
maybe it's this sellout sooo they were
shooting that you know I'm not wasn't
kind of corporate slave time to head to
sub urban for a new retrofit the new
updates got 170 new threads huh my dad's
gonna hate this match your bod with 8
new gestures and their counterparts ie
less talk
light rock and the flip metal get the
party started with the DJ put your hands
on the air and grab your ardex there's
the Queen Elizabeth oh hello and you can
shush down the ill-tempered good indie
look check time for a new ride rev up
with six new affordable whips start
smart with the benefactor panto soup it
up with some retro mods like this
original paint job or throw on some pure
black window tint but I think it's about
time for a selfie with my new viewers Oh
this greasy gas puzzler what a sellout
did they think I'd your hair officer
arrest this man
canto star so yesterday though Community
College is overrated dude suspend a
little more in Rhapsody which is an
undeniable reference to Wayne's World
so check it out with a light blue paint
job
flame decals and you got yourself the
Murph mobile
this horns not cutting it though it's
nice to know that there's four new ones
including one that loops and changes
speed as your car accelerates it's
totally not annoying and people really
seem to dig it just hold the left stick
and creep up on people like this guy
who's is a creep now and now he's going
to a strip club
Pigman you are an animal and you can be
one too with these new masks hurries be
stoked with pig owl or this crazy eyed
raccoon which really seems to bring out
my horn
Oh what's up guys I have the same car
okay it's time to throw up some D on
these LS phony make your arsenal artsy
with a new vintage pistol in antique
dagger hey what's up man come check out
this sweet smoke spot bro it's totally
safe up here I swear
not oh look hey it's big man sick kills
right I'm gonna reminisce those snuffs
with some ink choose 49 new tax to
separate yourself from all those
button-down consumers damn the sleeve is
the shiz but it's 10 grand an emo disco
fusion album can wait but all this bill
droppings really taking a toll on my PVR
crave well looks like they threw in a
dozen new jobs to make some of that
green bag you get ones like a new
parachute drop with a twisted landing
zone ouch B before it was cool panto
races got tight gene turns to squeeze
into the 2 in D capture jobs like grab a
cab steer away from the norm or hit up
the new team deathmatch and start
popping off squares with a vintage
pistol I could jam all night on the
other add-ons and fixes that came with
this update such as the 10 more vehicles
that were transferred over from the
campaign like this hot pink bf surfer
they even threw in the six wheeled six
seater dub stuff for ranked 100's to
roll round him for DLC this massive it's
hard to believe it's free
despite the sad delay of heists it's
nice to see Rockstar making some efforts
reward fans so for now turn that up to
11 and let it ride